speaking of TV are you a guy that always
gets the latest tech are you that person
you have to like update it every time
let me tell you about the latest tech
okay
I go to Best Buy right down here love
Best Buy okay and I'm looking for a
washer dryer
so a guy says to me let me show you a
new line of smart washers and dryers
I say what makes them smart the guy says
well they got Wi-Fi you know I said you
know I don't need Wi-Fi in my washer and
dryer the guy says no no it's added
value you buy the top of the line model
you get the Wi-Fi for free it's okay so
I buy the washer and dry with Wi-Fi for
the last two weeks I'm walking around
with damp underwear because I forgot my
password okay okay
I'm just saying
I never get it either all the like yeah
I never get I never do all the things
they tell you you can do with them why
do you need one it's so stupid I don't
need it to be smart I just need it yeah
this is a password thing that that
drives me crazy you know I I for some
reason my Netflix went off and then oh I
want to get it back so now I got to go
through mother's mate I'm on the phone
for an hour mother's maiden name with
someone so I it's you know the
password's just simple now well we've
got to check it okay it took an hour
okay
then my bank calls okay my bank calls
like two weeks later
uh you're transferring this amount of
money to this account uh oh yeah yeah
and what's your name I say I'm Jay Leno
okay thank you what that's it that's it
I mean I don't care if you steal my my
Netflix movie but my banking really I
mean it really it was is this channel
yes it is okay great but no way how do
you know
[Music]
that's so true Tech kills me every time
I don't even try anymore I just have
friends that I call that say why do I
need to know all this really yeah really
and it's like if you knew
how incredibly easy my passwords are
yes I'm just like
[Music]
just like
[Applause]
I'm going home
[Music]